if you're experiencing a mental health
crisis I think the first thing to do is
figure out what you need right so if
you're having trouble with your own
safety you're really thinking about
killing yourself you need to get help
and you need to see a professional or
you need to go to an emergency room not
everything can be done on a self-help
basis that said self-help and
self-management have become crucial
aspects of helping people do well so the
idea over time is to learn as much as
you can by joining groups like the
National Alliance on Mental Illness to
educate yourself to participate in your
own care in an active way that it's not
something the doctor is giving you a
medicine it's all forgotten you learn
about your condition you learn about the
stresses you learn about what it takes
to help you live the best way with it
once you understand that the crisis that
you're dealing with is probably known to
you and you should have a framework for
how to address future problems so the
key thing about thinking about a crisis
is how to get ahead of it how to learn
from prior vulnerabilities and how to
enroll people in your life to help you
anticipate it in a way that you can
accept their gentle feedback
when a person doesn't want help it
generates a tremendous challenge in all
the people who care about them how do
you help a person who isn't particularly
motivated or how do you deal with a
person who feels ashamed of their
symptoms because when you ask a person
do they need help the vulnerability that
they may feel the shame that they may
feel about knowing that their struggling
is one of the things that you're going
to be battling with so the first thing I
encourage them is to be gentle with
themselves this is not an easy thing
you're trying to take on then I
encourage people to think of overlapping
Venn diagrams you might see a psychotic
illness a problem hearing voices
difficulty with functioning and having
trouble getting out of bed they might
see getting out of bed is a problem and
I wish I had more to do so I encourage
people to ignore battling about their
diagnosis or their symptoms and focus on
the things that the other person wants
to do I wish I could get out of bed I
wish I could do more by work by starting
with things you can agree upon then
building upon them that's typically a
good way to get started you will
probably need professional help though
and professionals deal with this hard
topic all the time
in the wellness recovery action plan and
with any good caregiver the purpose of
the work is to identify patterns for you
that you can anticipate future
vulnerabilities some patterns to repeat
themselves so if you have depression
that occurs in the winter or if you have
bipolar episodes in the context of
relationship distress these become
predictable phenomena the idea of
creating an anticipation of your risk
for crisis is actually part of the
answer to dealing with a crisis so the
idea would be to understand if it's
seasonality relationship changes
medication changes that are risks for
you and then to identify a series of
things that you can do to minimize your
risk is it aerobic exercise is it having
a social role is it participating in
helping other people as a peer and
giving yourself a sense of meaning these
are the things that we find over and
over help people contend with reducing
their vulnerability so the earlier a
person gets help the better their
chances become people can recover and
live great lives one place to get help
is the Nami helpline the Nami helpline
is staffed by people who are living with
mental illnesses successfully and by
their family members the number is
you